Howard how we doing I'm doing great Ryan
how are you I'm doing really good thanks
for joining us absolutely so possibly
three Sunday 7 games abound we have the
big one tonight with Houston and Golden
State without Kevin Durant what have you
heard about the injury is it more than
what we're hearing from Steve Kerr is is
something that we may not see you the
rest of the year if they are able to get
past the Houston Rockets where are we at
with that well if it's any more serious
than a calf strain which is what they've
called it
they've done a pretty good job of
keeping a lid on it you know I I got to
just take it at face value at this stage
that it's a mild calf strain which is
what they publicly reported that he's
out for Game six and almost certainly a
Game seven if it comes to that and that
you know by you know middle of next week
maybe when we know where the Warriors
stand in the playoffs and he has a
chance to get reevaluated we'll see
whether or not he can reappear for the
Conference Finals but you know those
things are tricky you don't want to mess
around with it obviously they're going
to be cautious I'm sure and you know and
I think the real concern now is you know
you know you've got to play at least
this game without them tonight if you
lose this you've got a game seven
without them that's at home at least but
they're just missing such a huge piece
and I it's on many levels right not sure
it's not just their best most versatile
player and arguably the best player in
the game right now but they're just down
bodies they don't have DeMarcus Cousins
their bench was already thin to start
the season and to start this postseason
run they just you know I think the
concern right now is you how heavily
you've got three stars left but how
heavily can you ride those guys and ride
your core players to try to stave off
this Rockets team that's that's you know
given them fits anyway yeah I think it's
almost more about what those role
players can do to help move this Golden
State warrior team forward and not
necessarily say early about Steph Klay
and draymond but the guys that actually
haven't contributed because they haven't
been asked to this could be a huge
opportunity for them to step up and
really solidify them as the best team
together in the NBA certainly true but
you know what they have now in terms of
you know a bench is not what they
started this run with a few years ago
when their motto was strength in numbers
right like at that time they had you
know all these other pieces guys like me
Andrew Barbosa and a younger version of
Shaun Livingston and a younger version
of Andre Iguodala and you know and they
had Arison Barnes and so it was it was
the the three core guys in Steph clay
and dream on but then you had a bunch of
very capable solid top-tier type role
players and what they have now are guys
who they're still kind of trying to
bring along Kevon Looney he has his
moments and then he disappears and you
know makini clink hook whoever these are
you know they're they're good solid
players but they're not at the level
that you would prefer at this stage of
the season you know it in in a universe
in which they never signed Kevin Durant
there's more depth to this roster I'm
not saying that that's preferable they
won two championships with them but in a
universe where you never got him you've
got a much different composition of this
roster and what they have right now are
just a lot of guys who you'd prefer not
to have to lean on in a game of this
magnitude or in the Conference Finals
should they make it there yeah you're
talking about Kevin Durant we're
listening to Howard Beck MBA report or
senior NBA reporter from Bleacher Report
Steph looked as best when Kevin went out
the other day and I wonder if it's going
to look different in some way more
around what Steph can do and less about
what Kevin was doing because it it
clearly was a dominating force on his
end but but Steph Curry hasn't looked
this it looked itself until until Kevin
went down what do you think we're going
to see out of him not only tonight but
if there is a Game seven
without Kevin Durant on the court listen
you know Steph Curry the the talent
never went away
he certainly has taken a step back in
terms of usage during this a couple of
years here with Durant and that was that
was a plan that was the understood the
if you're going by Kevin Durant on to
your team
yeah and that was and that was an
incredible move by Steph Curry a guy
who's coming off back-to-back MVPs to
make room for another MVP and he has
still been incredible the last couple of
years he doesn't shine as bright as
often because he hasn't needed to he
needs to now he knows that the Warriors
know that I think we'll probably see
quite a bit of him tonight and you know
people if they've forgotten will be
reminded why he was a back-to-back MVP
in the first place it still comes down
to can he be effective without having to
play too many minutes or too many
consecutive minutes if the Rockets
really hone in on him defensively and
tried to just deny him those shots or to
just get physical with them who's giving
him that outlet
how much can klay Thompson do who else
in on that roster can really try to to
lift some of that that burden
you know that's again it still comes
back to that supporting cast you know we
know what curry can do and I have no
doubt he'll have a great game tonight
but they're gonna need more than that
they are in and from the Houston side of
things you know with boogie Cousins
being out there Center their top player
the best player in the NBA right now
probably in Kevin Durant if they don't
get it done this time
when will they yeah I mean it it really
it's the right question Ryan it'll be
this is what it's come down to for the
Rockets when they acquired Chris Paul
you know Paulie Chris and tall at that
time already really passed know they
well past his prime but late prime at
best when they got him and now this is
the end of the second year that they've
had him he's 34 he's got a lot of miles
on him you can see some of the erosion
in his game the Rockets know that every
day that goes by every month of games
that goes by they're potentially getting
that much less of a Hall of Fame caliber
Chris Paul and they did sign him to a
massive contract before this season
because that's what they had to do or
felt they had to do to keep them but
they know there's going to be
diminishing returns and so if you can't
knock off the Warriors tonight in
Houston to force the game seven and if
you if you can't win
Cirie's now with no Kevin Durant on the
floor I don't know that you ever will
now look
Durant could leave the Warriors as we
know the Warriors may not be the
Warriors next season and maybe maybe
James Harden Chris Paul in year three
can finally emerge from the Western
Conference but I just think that they
you know the the window is tight and
this is probably the best opportunity
they're gonna have we're listening to
Howard Beck senior NBA reporter from
Bleacher paw report
speaking of those scenarios right Kevin
Durant doesn't play these final two
games somehow Houston finds a way to win
free agency starts for him the first
domino that probably needs to go down
before anybody else does when the season
is all said and done what's your take
away if that were to play out in that
form whereas he doesn't play the end
they don't get out of the into the
Western Conference Finals is he of the
mindset of almost like unfinished
business with gold state or has he made
up his mind is he out of Northern
California and moving on now yeah I mean
it's like if it's possible to like make
a cloudy situation cloudy or um the
injury has kind of done that and if we
don't see him play again in this
postseason and he has to make the
decision in the wake of that yeah it's
it it's another element that nobody
anticipated the sense all season around
the league has been and I'm sure you've
seen this and heard it many many times
everybody around the league believes
that Kevin Durant is leaving and they
all believe that he's going to the
Knicks think that is almost universal I
have rarely if ever seen it like this in
the NBA where everybody you talk to has
the same sense of things now everybody
could just be hearing to say it could be
the game of telephone where one rumor
just you know made its way all the way
around and it's you know it maybe it's
it's it's just idle gossip and
everybody's sharing the same piece of
gossip but it's mostly because they've
been signals sent right there are
conversations that have been had and you
know there's there's a sense that this
decision has been telegraphed it doesn't
mean it will happen because ultimately
Kevin Durant can change his mind
if he had or even made up his mind maybe
it's more of a meaning than an actual
you know hardened and you know closed
book decision I think we're having to
season in this way it it throws in a
variable that I just don't even know how
to interpret the point has always been
if Kevin Durant leaves it's gonna be
because he's already won championships
and now he wants to go have his own team
again or he wants to achieve something
without it looking like he was jumping a
bandwagon which is what everybody
accused him of doing by going to the
Warriors so go save the Knicks for
instance and that'll be a different kind
of achievement and he'll get more credit
for it that might hold allure but you
know sticking with the team that is
going to a brand new arena in San
Francisco next year with few other stars
who you've been playing with and winning
championships with it's hard to walk
away from that I gotta believe and if
you have unfinished business because you
end up finishing this year on the Shelf
you can't how do you dismiss that right
I mean it was an interesting thought I
had about what that plays out to look
like and if it could actually change the
narrative of where it's going speaking
of free agency in the narrative Kyrie
Irving a guy that's going to attract and
demand a max deal is gonna walk into
free agency like the big stud probably
second domino to fall to Kevin Durant
yet he had one of the worst finishes you
can imagine in playoff history with with
the guy heading into a max contract
what's what what are you hearing about
Kyrie Irving
where's he looking is he looking to
reunite with with the dysfunctional
family of the LA Lakers here in Los
Angeles where where are we seeing things
playing out for Kyrie Irving right now I
think that his picture has gotten cloudy
or two you know if the Celtics had made
a deep run and things look good there
then you assume that he want him back in
your soon he wants to be back no matter
what else it happened during the season
but this postseason was such a disaster
for them you know it's not just they
went down in the second round I mean it
did lose to the to the top team in the
East but the Celtics were supposed to be
the top team in the East you know it's
you know it's they cannot possibly as an
organization be anywhere close to
satisfied with the way that this went
nor can Kyrie Irving
[Music]
a lot of this is on him it's not solely
on him a lot of it is their chemistry
was really screw up you're screwy all
season and some of that is Kyrie
Irving's kind of ham-handed attempts at
leadership and some of the things he
said about their younger players the way
he carries himself on the court the way
he plays and certainly in this series
where he was forcing the issue a lot
instead of being more of a distributor
and those are things that went back even
when he was in Cleveland winning the
title with LeBron people saw some of
these glitches in his game where you
know he was going to be indifferent on
defense at times and he was not going to
be much of a passer and the Celtics
demand more than that and it'll be
interesting to see how badly they even
want him back I mean are they going to
go all out to max him out to keep him
you know who walks away for who first
and Kyrie has been tied of course to KD
and so there's always been this thought
that with the Knicks getting you know
having to max slots available to them
that the combination the preferred
combination was Durant and Kyrie in
tandem they are good friends and you
know no one will be shocked if that's
what happens I do think that anybody
who's chasing Kyrie should probably pay
attention to what just happened in
Boston we're talking to Howard Beck from
Bleacher Report's senior NBA writer the
disaster scenario you talking about his
is simply played out here in Los Angeles
we watched it take form at the UCLA job
where it's supposed to be the the mecca
for coaches John Wooden started here
then we look at LA Pat Riley and the
championships won but instead they have
the second coach walk away in just the
in a week where do they go from here and
what does that mean for LeBron the buses
everything LA Laker you know I covered
that team for seven years during the
Shaq and Kobe era and you know drama was
kind of always a Laker hallmark they do
drama as well as any one appropriate to
their you know to their location but it
back then it was well Shaq and Kobe are
fighting and they want to kill each
other but hey in the meantime they're
winning championships and sometimes
there's a little bit of tension between
maybe coaching for office for an office
an ownership in it happens it happens
with
with you know even the best of
organizations what we're seeing from the
Lakers right now is a whole other level
of dysfunction that I don't think
anybody anticipated we'd ever see from
the Lakers not from an organization with
their history and their accomplishments
and it's stunning to see it's it's a
little disturbing to see I hope they
figure it out I still know people in
that organization and would like to see
them get this thing back on track but
right now I think the Lakers should be
embarrassed about the way this whole
offseason has unfolded it's you know I
almost forgot to mention even the part
of Magic Johnson up and leaving without
even talking to I mean it's it's it's
considerably a a place where you thought
LeBron was going to go and kind of ride
off into the sunset at the end of his
career become a Hollywood mogul instead
there were rumors this week about Jeanne
bus trading him so how is this going to
get fixed who is the next head coach
what is that going to look like and when
is that announcement gonna happen
I wouldn't even hazard a guess the way
that this coaching search has gone and
as close as it seemed as they were
getting to hiring Tehran glue and then
seemingly botching that I wouldn't even
try to build some Italy hire I mean
let's go back to Magic Johnson leading
that was considered while shocking and
and not handled well was considered a
blessing in disguise in that most people
around the league thought well this is a
chance for them to reset Magic Johnson
robbed pálinka as a phenomena stand 'm
never made a ton of sense but magic
leaving gave them a chance to reassess
and maybe think listen let's get it at
experienced front office executive in
here you know hired David Griffin or
find somebody else out there hire
somebody who's number two from permanent
from one of the successful teams from
local Homer or San Antonio or the
Warriors you'll go out and get somebody
who's done this before and they didn't
do that and the result is they've got
this haphazard now search for a coach
and it's going about as I think you
would expect yeah it certainly has
speaking of unknowns we have the big
games this weekend starting tonight I
would like to ask where you think it's
going to go are we gonna get three game
sevens on Sunday and if so who who's
playing Milwaukee and who's playing in
the Western Conference Finals well we've
got two game sevens for sure of course
and we'll see if the Rockets can force a
third and it's going to make a lot of
mother's days very awkward because too
many of us are going to be camped out in
front of TVs watching three game sevens
instead of going brunch but game sevens
are fun you listen I still think the
Warriors pull this out I think we see
them in the conference finals
the Denver Portland game I mean that to
me it's a coin flip but it is in Denver
that's a tough place where for teams to
play because of the altitude the Nuggets
have a you know it haven't always had a
great home crowd but it's been really
reinvigorated and it's it's it's you
know I think a good atmosphere there I
feel like that one's a coin flip in the
east you know I think Toronto pulls it
out I mean they're there they and the
Sixers are obviously very closely
matched I mean there's a reason it's
tied three-three the Sixers have more
overall star power the Raptors are
fantastic at home defensively they can
really lock in and I I'm guessing it's
Toronto Milwaukee in the East and you
know warriors and probably the Nuggets
in the West but you know game sevens man
it's a coin flip yeah it is it's gonna
be a fun weekend you're right that's an
example of what Sunday's going to look
like for a lot of Suns out there who are
having to do some fun things with their
mom or maybe postpone them Howard Beck
from Bleacher Report senior NBA writer
thank you so much for joining us and
have a great weekend and join these ball
games
absolutely Ryan you too thicker for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app